my name is Raja droppeth I'm a product
specialist here at Google for the
Android platform and today I'll be
sharing with you some key updates from
the Android and synapse team including a
lot of the efforts that we're doing to
scale the product as well as sharing
details and best practices and key
learnings from a lot of our partners who
have launched in synapse at the end I'll
introduce John on stage and we'll have
them talk about a lot of the work that
they did to actually get their instant
app up and running and hopefully we can
learn from what they did as well so
let's start by actually reviewing a lot
of the work that our team has done up
until this point as I'm sure you all
know Android and synapse officially
launched back at Google i/o in May any
developer can now build an instant app
and publish that instant app to the Play
Store and what's been really exciting
for me is to actually see apps in places
that they really weren't ever in before
you know you can see things like
previously with the Play Store was the
gatekeeper to all the traffic and
engagement that you had as a developer
or you had to configure very complex
deep links to get users inside your
native experience but users are now
actually accessing your native
experience across all of these different
services from Google search to email and
messaging and even from Twitter I'm also
really happy to announce that we've now
enabled over 800 million devices
globally for instant apps which is
actually well over the 500 million
devices that we enabled only just eight
weeks ago so we're actually accelerating
a lot of the a lot of the internet usage
that users are able to access and we're
really working hard to make sure that
users are able to experience these these
instant app experiences now looking at
all these new services to drive users
into the into your instant app we asked
ourselves what could we be doing on Play
to actually help drive your users to
those experiences that's why I'm really
happy to announce the try Now button for
instant apps that have a default URL
users will be able to navigate
two year Instant app from your Play
Store listing here you can see the try
Now button for Skyscanner
when a user taps on the try Now button
they are taken to the Skyscanner instant
app users are still able to install your
full app nothing is going to change with
that and in fact we're seeing that we're
not seeing any cannibalization from that
experience either we're really excited
about this initial bit of results this
is still an experimentation but it
should be rolling out hopefully very
soon the other piece that I want to talk
about too on the platform side is that
we're also making it really easy for
users to engage and discover these in
synaptics periences from android which
is why we've integrated on the launcher
and we're also adding the feature to pin
your instant app to home the idea behind
this is to basically give users more
abilities to interact with your instant
app experience and ensure that users are
actually able to experience these across
all these new surfaces this is rolling
out as part of the latest o update
that's going to be happening in the next
month or so so by the end of the year we
expect users to actually be able to
access this on o devices now in order to
make all these features work for you
you'll need to set up what we call a
canonical landing page this ensures that
when users come to your instant app you
know by a button like try now or through
the launcher integration that I just
showed you on the screen they'll have
essentially like a home screen
experience
previously when users would tap when
you're in San AB they tap on a deep link
and then they're taken to a very
particular moment such as watching a
video or booking a restaurant but with
this default URL they're now able to
access a home screen experience on your
instant app Skyscanner one football Red
Bull TV all of these apps have canonical
landing pages and it's really easy to
set up in the manifest and we encourage
all of you as you're building your
instant app to set up a default URL to
take advantage of these new services
that are coming up all right so the team
and I are very happy with a lot of the
progress that we are seeing and the
scale we've achieved with the product
but I'm gonna shift gears a little bit
and talked about some of the best
practices and key learnings from many of
the partners that we're seeing who are
live within synapse today we've talked
to hundreds of developers around the
world and I've been involved in a lot of
those conversations so I can say it's
definitely been a lot of developer
conversations and in in many cases the
first conversation that we always have
is all about what is your use case what
do you want to what do you want a user
to do when they're in your native
experience now that they don't have to
actually install your app do you want to
increase the conversion on your shopping
cart do you want to get people to watch
more videos jet was able to actually
increase their conversions by 27 percent
and Vimeo saw 130 percent increase in
engagement with their videos just by
having users drive into their instant
app understanding your use case and what
you want to achieve is critical
understanding the kinds of user journeys
that you want to create for your instant
app experience I'm also happy to see
that developers are actually building
new Android apps and are thinking about
instant apps from day one the concept of
modular izing your code is not something
new everyone in the audience has been
thinking about that but as instant apps
become more embedded in the Android
platform it's imperative to think about
modular ization and instant apps as one
before you start building hit list up
here had modularization and in synapse
in mind when they started Android
development only eight weeks ago as a
result they had a working prototype of
their instant app experience in under
six weeks and we expect them to actually
get the full launch in the next two
weeks now a key portion of the work
involved in building your instant app is
actually building the modules for each
of the instant app experiences I'm happy
to announce as part of the latest SDK
release which just went out a week ago
we've recently enabled configuration
apks as well as launching a shared
library support in q4
now configuration apk is separate apk
resources for pictures strings layout
files Bay
on-device architecture language and
screen density that allows you to
generate config splits according to your
specific needs
ensuring users only get a single set of
resources for any single instant app
experience for example if the apk has
English French Spanish and Italian
resources inside and the end user is
using a Spanish device play is only
going to deliver the Spanish resources
to that particular user saving you space
on your actual module that you can use
for your own for your own experiences
and for your code
additionally in speaking to a lot of
partners live with instant apps they
found that there was a lot of
low-hanging fruit in terms of simple
optimizations for reducing apk size such
as removing unused assets that were
simply not needed for their instant app
as well as compressing pictures using
technologies like web P many partners
viewed the refactoring work as a part of
a larger code how to exercise and we're
able to rework their codebase in a
modular code structure in mind last our
team is actually in the process of
testing shared library support and we
expect that to go live in q4 the idea
here is to help with module size limits
by allowing you to reuse code that would
be helpful for shared resources across
your different instant app experiences
the idea here is for us to help reduce
latency for the end user but also make
sure that you have plenty of available
space to stay within the module size
limit to deliver whatever experience you
want to have for your users now we're
really bullish on in synapse because
we're excited about all the new user
interactions that are actually coming up
that has this is enabled for you as
partners we're starting to see a few key
UX considerations emerge as we've talked
to partners who have gone live with
instant apps and we want to make sure
that we share those best practices with
you guys now a lot of our partners are
reconsidering their success metrics as
an industry and as an ecosystem for the
past nine years we've been simply
talking about installs constant
that's not to say that we're gonna
change that but remember now that as you
remove the install ask yourself what do
I really want the user to achieve post
install do I want them to buy a ticket
do I want them to book a restaurant do I
want them to send a message watch a
video you have the user captured at that
moment so look at that KPI as as your
biggest metric now partners who have
been able to use the same code based on
a learning project are also seeing
benefits in terms of code maintenance a
lot of our early partners actually built
a separate code base specifically for
instant apps just to get their feet wet
just to see what the experience was like
but actually a lot of them have moved
over to reusing a lot of the same code
that they have in their fully installed
experience in order to make sure that
their their code is in sync and also
their user experiences are in sync some
of the best partner experiences ensure
that they don't interfere with task
completion now this is a really big one
because you have to remember when a user
taps on a URL they're not asking
themselves am I going to a native
experience or an installed app or a
mobile web experience they just want to
send a message they just want to book a
restaurant they just want to watch a
video so the last thing you'd want to do
is to interrupt that that flow for the
user by asking them to insta log into
your app or create an account or go
through some sort of tutorial you never
want to actually break a user flow post
install and you'll find a lot better
results once you allow the user to
complete a full journey and last
remember to maintain the user state from
instant app into the installed app there
are some updates in the latest SDK where
we allow you to actually carry over a
lot more detail from your instant app
into the installed app so you can
imagine as a users interacting with your
instant app you're actually able to take
a lot of the data that you gathered from
there
Raj watched a certain video or he made a
certain message or something along those
lines and then provide me with a warm
install once I actually installed the
app
cool sorry alright so all the items that
I pointed out on the last slide are
aimed at simply reducing friction on
mobile we said about building Android in
synapse because we felt the friction
from installing an app was simply
unnecessary
in a similar vein we provide tools like
smart lock for passwords as well as the
new Google payment API to reduce
friction on authentication as well as on
payments now I'd like to invite John
from LA for shut up to the stage to talk
about his experiences with building an
instant app please join me in welcoming
John hi I'm very happy to be here my
name is John I'm responsible for the
apps at rafet Lafourche it is a
restaurant booking company were present
in 11 countries mostly across Europe and
as the company our goal is pretty simple
is connecting the right restaurant to
the right customer at the right time so
in other words it's reducing that
friction that you may have when booking
a restaurants reducing that friction
which is coating the restaurant waiting
for it to be opened waiting for someone
to answer and then having to talk to
someone who's busy answering other
clients so you'd be really surprised to
know how how many people still call the
restaurants to book to book a
reservation and without instant app was
a good way of reducing that friction so
the use case rise you made it very clear
it's very important to rightly select
your use case and for us our key success
metric is the booking this is basically
how we are evaluated and this is in the
end how we make money so when we make
product decisions we always optimize for
bookings so when we looked at instant
apps we we looked at our
mobile web traffic and when you look at
this data what you find out is that a
huge majority of our traffic comes from
Google and comes from people who
directly type the name of a restaurant
in Google so recognize that for this
group of users they already know the
name of the restaurants they know at the
number of people that will go there they
know the date they know the hour etc so
we don't want them to download the app
to sign up for an account to search the
restaurant again that's way too much of
a hassle for a first experience with our
brand so in this context instant tap
allowed us to allow the user to perform
the action directly he just searches for
the restaurants makes the booking and
and it's done it was really an
opportunity to to improve our our key
metric again which is the bookings how
did it go
so in back in March when we joined the
instant app early access program Google
asked us one thing which was to be ready
before Google i/o and that left us with
three weeks that's really not a lot for
our two reasons and those were two big
challenges that ended up as
opportunities the first one is the
legacy code of our app especially for
the booking flow it was full legacy and
as you know Instant a power all about
modular architecture modular code which
means that the feature should be able to
run independently that was pretty scary
but in the end it was rather fast we
decided to start from scratch and to
redevelop the booking process and in
less than two weeks that that was done
also
because because we started modular using
our app we found out all of the
advantage that proved to us and now
every new feature that we are developing
is based on this new modular architect
sure which means that turning those
features into instant app is very very
quick and it's almost painless so if
your features are ready modular this
wouldn't cost you much and if they're
not it's really an opportunity to
modularize record the second challenge
was the sizes so your instant tab
shouldn't be more than four megabytes
and in those four megabytes you have
shared resources which are not directly
your feature so we had to find ways to
reduce the the size of our instant app
the first thing we did was to assess the
libraries we had for instance we found
out that fresco was a library that was
way too big it it was almost as big as
the instant app itself so removed it we
removed this one and we replaced it
button by another one and our main app
now benefits from those changes in terms
of designs we couldn't with this four
megabytes limits have P energies for
design assets so we moved to fully
vector all assets we asked our design
team to provide us with those and now
this is something we still do right now
for our new features and our benefits
from it results because the experience
is better with an internal app we see a
better conversion rate and that's once
again key for us booking is our key
metric so when we have an increase in
conversion rate this means we get more
money also we found out that this allows
us to open our experience to new users
because we usually we have about 10% of
users who book from a restaurant that is
not in their own country because we made
the brand available to people who don't
know our brand
we now have this share reaching 30% so
it's a good way of reaching customers
who otherwise wouldn't go to Lafayette
what's next
first thing we'll do is optimize the
user flow we'll we'll try to reduce the
number of steps then one key thing we'd
like to to make is develop the
restaurant page as an instant app as you
understood we try to leverage the huge
volume of traffic that comes from Google
and most of this traffic is on the
restaurant page because people type
directly a restaurant name so when we'll
manage to have this restaurant page
motorized and available as an instant
app we'll be able to offer a full
experience native experience to users
without app installation search for
restaurant name in google land on the
native restaurant page with video and a
native map and then go to the native
booking flow and then we'd like to
implement canonical page that were just
announced and leverage the icon launcher
that will be available on Android
so in the end instant tap brought us two
things the first thing is incremental
traffic and bookings and the second
thing is that it brought us a service
screen of our code base which was a good
thing thank you and back to you rash
thank you John Poole so it's great to
see what they've accomplished in such a
short amount of time and I'd like to
leave you with three key things to
remember in synapse is about discovery
and engagement not just reducing
friction on mobile remember that this
somewhat represents a paradigm shift in
how we've been thinking about apps so
far because while we remove the install
we're now asking you to think about what
do you want to drive the user to do once
they're in your native experience we're
here to help you with development and
design and we recognize that this work
can be pretty heavy but we're hoping to
see we're hoping that you can see that
the benefits for your codebase are very
clear and can also affect your bottom
line as well and we're deeply embedding
instant apps across both the OS and the
platform from the launcher to pin to
home to other features that we're
working on currently and we're really
excited for what's in store for instant
apps going forward
you